uh
food safety council or conference
education china in july of 2014
and the reason they held it is between
2012 and 2014
they saw a 59 percent increase in cancer
rates
and whenever grain comes in from
argentina
now they've got 1.4 billion people and
if they have a lot of sick people
or autistic children which is growing
erratically they just cannot afford it
bob can i ask you to stand over here
should i
we'll get a better song of the life
right here would be perfect right there
you may have to move if i'm going to
stand here and so
as long as you can see it i'm good so
they know if they can't
have that continued increase
they can't afford it as we can here
now will it make a difference china is a
different country i got home and my wife
asked are you ready to go back
i thought a little bit and i said no i
don't think so why
i'm not that big on eating cooked
cabbage the beds were as hard as the
floor here
everything was foreign if you ate food
and it was a chicken dish they cut up
the chicken and they leave the
bone fragments in the food so
and pollution was terrible but the top
seven generals in the chinese army were
in the front row of the audience
and that's the biggest market for
our soybeans in the world they
basically import 67 percent of the
exported soybeans in the world
and roughly 50 to 55 percent of the u.s
soybeans end up in china feeding people
there
and there will be some major changes in
their consumption and soybean supply
anyhow we think the message about
healthy food is getting home
the successful farming magazine is
published by meredith
publishing in des moines iowa and they
ran a mid-february
issue 2016. it was entitled farmers meet
your new boss
and it was a 12 star nine segment 12
page story i can send copies to people
but in there they said the millennial
shopper
that's 30 to 35 years old or maybe 30
to 40 they want
healthy food they want happy families
they want good nutrition
in their food and they said
farmers even if you don't like the
message recognize that these shoppers
will make up
say 70 of the shopping public in about
10 years
so you better adapt and we went and
talked to the head editor
dave kearns a few days after they showed
up and we thanked him for writing it
and we asked are you expecting any
negative feedback he said yes we're
going to the big uh
actual here uh commodity classic and
we're expecting people to come up and my
we've already prepared our answer and
that is we publish 34 magazines in
different languages
and we also publish like ladies home
journal and
quite a few women's magazines and they
knew that uh roughly 100 million
women a month read their magazine and
they said we like
producing the best producing circulating
in different countries the best farm
magazine possible
we also do the same for women's
magazines we did our survey we know what
the
five top hot hot buttons are for women
and it's healthy food happy families
good nutrition
so if any of the egg producers or any
people disagree with us we'll let them
argue with a hundred million mad women
so uh i like uh part of what i'm here
for is to share this
news and then also interact with people
and hopefully
learn about some markets where we can
connect some midwest producers
to maybe consumers out here i'm involved
in a big food project that we may move
on to different countries
but 30 miles north of me in central iowa
will be the biggest fish farm
in the nation by this fall and within
five years after five planned expansions
it will
be the biggest in the world they're
raising barramundi
which are australian sea bass so they
went after the higher dollar eight
dollar pound fish markets to the two
dollar
pound tilapia market which is a bottom
feeding fish
anyhow uh nutrient uptake by 200 bushel
corn which is kind of the standard
servings is listed here and basically
the number one used herbicide which is
from company in saint louis
uh chelates all of these they're all
listed here
uh richard olrey is speaking quite a bit
today he's a good friend
and he likes to work with pubmed
and he looked at those minerals and he
figured out what percent
of the genes that are in the human
construct involved those minerals
he said roughly 59 of them and that's
why we're seeing a lot of the diseases
in there and i'll get heavier into that
uh bob i need you to stay in between
those two lines or else you're not on
screen for the life
people are actually following this life
okay right there it's fine
[Music]
now people are asking is that the
education the herbicide or
is it the insertion of the gene that's
causing the problem
and uh basically at universities uh no
one gets a grant to do this
work or these studies unless they have
permission from the seed companies
they're not going to do that the two
people that have done it is ishmael
catmac at purdue
and then luis zobioli out of mourinho
brazil when he was studying with bob
kramer at university of missouri
but they looked just at the insertion of
the trait and they found
pretty significant decrease in those
minerals
in the plant and the thing is most of
those minerals are those
uh manganese boron copper and zinc
if the plants are missing them they're
going to be very prone to disease attack
and dying from
uh fungal disease probably a root
disease if humans are deficient in those
minerals
they're also going to get sick and very
likely end up with alzheimer's
okay there's rich's slide
there is a chart that shows a
correlation or the chelation quotient
between
the glyphosate product and the different
minerals
and quite a few of them chart is
available
what we urge farmers to do now though is
take a closer look
at their fertility programs number one
when they pull soil tests we urge them
that if they haven't been looking at
those micronutrients
pay attention to it part of the problem
and lack of decent nutrition
to the plants and to the people is that
most of these tasks will detect if the
mineral is there
but it won't detect if it's plant
available or if it's being calated by a
stronger compound
which is the case okay here's the work
uh
you know i got that in there twice yeah
what we're seeing in probably 90
of the fields right now is a general uh
instead of a dark green color we got
light green dark green streaking
and there were a lot of publications
20 years ago where they diagnosed it and
there was a chart called be your own
corn doctor
if you're showing this discoloration
it's shortage of
sulfur or nitrogen if you're showing
this zinc or another mineral
we don't see that as much anymore and
most farmers
look at it and their agronomists don't
know about it universities aren't
telling them what to look for so
the teachers aren't trained but if we
see that
the plant is going to be much more
drought prone stress grown
subject to disease attack and also
diseases more likely to show up which
was the case
now in north central iowa i like flying
a friend of mine builds his own
airplanes and he wins the
top prize for homebuilt and oshkosh
wisconsin
so he's safe to fly with but we're going
over fields
southwest of fort dodge iowa north
central early august of 2010
and all the corn underneath it should be
dark green it's not
it's brown it's dead from a new disease
brought on by lack of nutrition
and bacteria that moved into the corn
crop and that happened to be the same
bacteria collaborator
that was used as the promoter when they
did the first bt
project
anyhow these are soybean fields they
should all be dark green
instead they were attacked by a fusarium
fungus which is a root rot again
caused due to lack of nutrition
everything should be dark green
why these are significant is guess where
the food supply is coming from
oftentimes
from these disease fields
uh two great uh kind of case studies
that were done
by lay people are written up in books
one is called animal farm
and that's p-h-a-r-m written by mark
purdy who is an organic british dairy
farmer that did not believe the official
explanation of what was called mad cow
disease or bse
which is caused by a biomatrix that we
commonly call a prion
the other one is when you chelate
cobalt with a herbicide it's not
available
you will demyelinate your nerve sheath
and you'll end up like a famous baseball
player called lou gehrig
and uh if you happen to go to a dentist
and he's talking about giving nitrous
oxide
you may tell the dentist i want to beat
our cobalt test
first because if you're exposed to
nitrous oxide it converts the
valency of the cobalt from plus one to
the plus two or plus three
valency and it will not be body
available and as i mentioned to a few
people
i played softball in iowa falls
in our good second baseman ended up
being a superintendent in school after
he got his doctorate
and he went in for a small dental
procedure and he never woke up from the
anesthetic
and it may have been this as the root
cause so
if people are around different uh
products that chelate it there are
things you can do
in this case we tell people if they're
using liberty herbicide
to uh take b12 supplements or get some
losses
or actually get a b12 shot core atom and
b vitamins
is cobalt uh going a little bit further
into that
uh investigation as far as why the
eighty percent of the u.s corn crop was
dying early
we ended up getting referred to dr chris
johnson
who was a head researcher
specializing in prions at the national
fish and wildlife research group in
madison wisconsin
and i dropped some samples off with him
and they tested it and they got a coke's
postulate which is where you
take a disease plant isolate the
organism
and test or treat another new plant
healthy plant with it and it comes down
to the same disease
then that's called fulfilling colt's
postulate
but he wrote a a good article on it but
he was censored and never got published
so what we've been working on in the
full investigation has been
we've been working on since 2009 when
the disease first showed up
and the full investigation has been
going on since 1999
it still hasn't come to a full
conclusion but
there's a few good books to read one
actually started out with kurt vonnegut
jr
because he helped solve the riddle as
far as something that is not
living can replicate and as his brother
as it turned out he would discuss
crystal work with his brother who
happened to be a crystal researcher at
mit
and they would talk about this at
thanksgiving dinner and such
and he took the talk about crystals
replicating and put it in his book
called cat's cradle
but another good book deadly feast by i
think richard rhodes
and it was a story about
a epidemiologist medical doctor that was
working with cannibals in new guinea
and at the start of the story they
describe a feast where granny is both
the guest of honor the main course
but they had a strange neurological
disease show up called kuru
so a fellow by the name of uh
well then following that was uh
mark purdy who was an organic british
dairy farmer that didn't believe the
official explanation
and he found out that the mad cow was
showing up when they had a deficiency in
copper
an excess of manganese and exposure to
high levels
of em emission that was sent off a
cascade
but the prions that were in their brain
that are used to store long-term
memories in normal humans
or in the prc form but when they're
exposed to the high levels
of em emission and the other factors
they convert
to the infected prpcs form
and the person that did the best work
was probably a fellow named stanley
prusner who was a neurologist at
university of california san francisco
he worked on it 20 to 25 years
it was his passion everyone says the
dead end
he ended up winning the nobel prize in
medicine
in 1997. now if these are in the food
supply
if they're in the body the way to get
them out is by
taking a mineral called clinoptillolite
c-l-i-n-o-p-t-i-l-o-l-i-t-e
and it is ground zeolite which is used
in an aquarium to take the nitrogen out
of the water it's a volcanic mineral
if they grind it at one to three
nanometers in size at 105 degree angle
and it's considered clean up to light
but uh
is probably the number one cause for low
birth rates in the us because the freon
considers the fetus as nutritional rival
and how we found it is in a high
percentage of young animals
who are being miscarried during the mid
stages of pregnancy
the aborted placental tissue ended up
being
full filled with these little crystals
and
diagnostic our vet pathologists that did
the staining in the autoclaving
uh ended up finding it in the feed
source which was a soybean meal at that
time
but harvard medical is researching these
as far as how
they're connected to arteriosclerosis
parting of the arteries
arthritis cataracts and alzheimer's
anyhow uh i happen to go with don huber
the top ag
scientist in the world on a seven-day
road trip we took pictures in an
industrial scanning electron microscope
i got these pictures here at anywhere
from fourteen thousand to a hundred
eighty thousand times magnification
and these are coming from corn and
soybean tissue from the midwest
chinese found them right away in
soybeans imported from the us
they just screw the plants up from the
seed split the leaves open
in the scope or slide
to catch the juice that flowed out of
the leaves and they found that
i mentioned uh as far as verification of
this uh
dr claudio soto at the university of
texas health services wrote a big
article probably the best one on it
and there's stanley cruz nerf's work
he's still alive
uh harvard our washu in st
louis has a true lab they do the work
there also and there's a lot of faculty
go between washu
and harvard and i've talked to a few of
the people
and they're correlating it with 24 other
human diseases
and if you don't have the 45 years
experience as a vet pathologist
know how to stain it and do the
autoclave work
you're never going to find these you're
never going to see these
they made a few bad assumptions and that
is the they said
they were reductionists they said the
presence of one gene controlled the
expression one type
and what they know now is genetic system
press our one trait typically is
controlled by the electromagnetic
interaction between bullseye
so it's a lot more complicated than that
and also what they didn't know
is that every human has two to five
pounds of bacteria
in their gut and those bacteria
are responsible for extracting nutrients
controlling human health and also make
up roughly
uh seventy percent of the immune system
in people okay we
basically all pesticides that they have
in fact most herbicides might keep
work by chelating minerals but the
history of pesticides basically starts
in europe
pre-world war one and the big company is
called ig
farming and farben is a german word for
colors and they were making industrial
dies out of coal tar
now when after world war ii they had the
nuremberg trials and basically ig farben
was split up into three
companies basf bayer and uh
hurst works so and then in this country
we had uh
pyrethroids were developed by the
british
from chrysanthemum flowers
and then we in this country we had
efforts at
fort detrick and that's basically where
we worked
to counter the activity of the russians
that was detailed in a book called
biohazard
adhd is a major problem right now what's
the cause of it
and what they know is basically insects
nervous system is very similar to that
of humans
so if you work with colonist race
inhibitors
or nerves in insects
and people are exposed to that either as
direct
say drift or exposure
through the food or air they're very
unlikely to have some of the same
problems and if you talk to any teachers
at work with grade school kids
discipline is oftentimes our number one
problem
as far as leaky gut and all of that i
was involved in this project
i still have a 30 year old t-shirt
hanging
one time should she throw it away i said
no it's a gold mine but what it was
trying to uh create insect resistant
corn
and they did it by taking a genetic
sequence from
uh soil dwelling bacteria called
bacillus thuragensis or bt
and they were using clavibacter bacteria
to put it into corn
and anyhow it was great because number
one problem grazing corn in the western
corn belt is european corn bark
that came from europe
and supposedly up the economy during
world war one
but if that's happened uh they theorized
that it was only be effective against
insects that have
an alkaline gut not something with an
acidic gut
but it looks like there are some of
their assumptions were wrong
because if kids are having a problem
with leaky gut
it's major problem behavior problems and
then oftentimes
it breaks the blood-brain barrier
so they have done a lot of microtoming
of different
gut cells they know that
one type of food causes basically a
breakdown of the gut lining
loss of integrity loss of attackness
with and without and they have got the
medical proof that there is an actual
problem
it's not mental uh we really needed
uh to explain this whole thing and to
work with us over in china
present good evidence we needed the help
of two good
human biochemists we end up getting help
from a guy named anthony sam south who i
believe
is up in new hampshire
not a raspy old guy but very intelligent
he started doing the work after he would
he's got some greenhouses that he works
in at his house
and he would just be into a bucket
instead of going outside in the cold
winter he noticed
uh when he's poured the bucket onto
plants that would kill them so he
thought maybe i've got something in me i
should check out so
he ended up forcing all of monsignors
getting and acquiring all of monsanto's
secret
research results through the freedom of
information act
anyhow he partnered up with steph center
who's a head biochemist at mit they've
written six
major review papers about 30 to 40 pages
in length
very heavy reading but if you read are
going to be pretty much kind of
impartial expert on it
we're also seeing a lot of uh
different parts of the country where the
price of combines has gotten quite
expensive
the if they have to hire in
uh combines to harvest their crop
they want to stay on schedule and they
will spray their
crop to
desiccate it so was all right say next
tuesday when the cutting crew gets here
and uh the systemic herbicide
that late in the season will be sprayed
on the leaves and it will be transported
directly
to the growing point which at that point
is the brain
so a lot of the people that think that
gluten intolerance actually might be
very allergic about creating symptoms
due to the glyphosate that is contained
in there
so we really need a replacement for it
and there's good progress coming on that
but read these papers it's
samsel incentive number one two three
four
five and six and they're already working
on seven eight
at night again nancy swanson
basically showed the correlation
between uh bt corn acres
and colitis and crohn's crohn's is a
nasty disease that
if you haven't his lifetime
affliction i lost a sister to it
there are alternatives out there there's
a fellow named bob quinn
uh farms up montana he run grows the
ancient wheats that were selected for
digestibility and flavor rather than
being able to be processed quite easily
so he raises
grains like commute and spelt grinds
them and sells under the label
bob's red mill and those are
alternatives
sanaf did work on it as have other
people
and there's a strong correlation between
gut microbes and obesity
if you throw off the gut population and
you move away from having
lactobacillus enterococcus and biofidium
as your major three bacteria
and move towards salmonella e coli and
clostridium you'll have major problems
a lady by the name of dergena stanley
teaches at queensland university in
australia and she has found out that if
they do fecal transplants
and include specific bacteria
in the transplant you can actually cure
autism and diabetes she's done the work
but when she writes
she always writes like she's doing it on
poultry
and that way she disguises her results
but uh there is an obesity switch and it
looks like that's being affected
uh you go to other parts of the world
and the number of people
grossly overweight is down quite a bit
i guess i've been impressed with the
shape of the people here it looks like
there's a lot of marathoners and such
but you go to different parts of the
world
germany argentina you can tell they're
starting to drink a lot of
pop and consuming
high fructose corn syrup which hopkins
found out doesn't
get digested for usage it gets towards
fat right away
anyhow brings up the question is roundup
in our food and if you're eating a
modern
uh drive-through diet or a fast food
diet
hamburger cheeseburger with french fries
during pop there's quite a few different
ways where the glyphosate can get into
your system
and it looks like it's involved in a
high percentage of major diseases
they actually tested honey zen honeycut
with mothers across america did one
study a friend of mine did another one
they looked at honey from northwest iowa
again
honey is made from nectar and pollen
from flowers and if you got
pesticide drip landing on those flowers
it's picked up in the honey
so more places than you think
there's quite a bit of talk yesterday at
the pre-meeting about instruments that
could be used to detect it
this device is what's called an x-ray
diffraction
instrument from broker which is a
massachusetts country
it's it looks like a giant squirt gun
and
uh it does cost on it there's two
tools that come with it together it's
about 63 thousand dollars
and it was repurposed our broker
requested that dr jill clapperton
who's the number one or two number uh
best
soil microbiologists in the world
repurpose it so she is using it
and she is putting food products in the
tray be it
uh a fruit a vegetable processed grain
and egg or peel off an orange it will
analyze for all 94 minerals in about
75 to 80 seconds and it'll give you a
total
rundown on it and part of the goal is to
have these out there
it also picks up small molecules which
would include
pesticides and pharmaceuticals
and i work quite a bit with jill and i
ask
that the number three library be built
for mycotoxins because more and more
people are being exposed to
bacteria or fungal mold or is coming
through the grain
we're seeing a major problem with if our
farmers have grain that basically
rots and they can't feed it to their
livestock they will take it to an
ethanol plant
and the ethanol plant will basically
concentrate the mycotoxins
3x and then they try to sell it as ddgs
to
other livestock feeders if they don't
accept it they try to get rid of it
in animal food pet food
and also human food and we've got places
where the dogs
will not bread anymore
in iowa and major problem
in humans uh
exposure to some of them the symptoms
will range from
uh refusal to feed or to
esophageal cancer so major problems also
adhd
uh what the 65 000
instrument will replace is probably one
that runs
350 to 500 thousand dollars the state of
the art
is uh the so-called lc tandem ms
we're working on a scanner that we hoped
would be out two years ago in june
um designed and built by the jet
propulsion lab engineers price point was
going to be 250
and a housewife could take it in scan
all of her food before she bought it
for mineral content and pesticides
but uh things kind of fell apart on that
dan was involved and dan has visited
with
the engineers on it very smart people
it's not completely dead i found out
this summer
one thing if you've got relatives in
florida let them know that they probably
need to do something with their water
this is a slide of data taken by
a well water survey taken by the u.s
geological survey
group which is in the department of
interior
but is well water in central florida and
everything in the pink area uh is
contaminated with the number one
used herbicide partly because the citrus
growers have been using
20 gallons of roundup per acre
on some of their ground for 20 years now
they excuse me 20 pounds they're putting
on four gallons
five times a year four quarts five times
a year yeah
okay now i i'd gas with that figure
this shows that if you're irrigating
corn
with 28 inches of water which typical in
their sandy soil
they calculated how much glyphosate
would be pumped per acre or per square
mile
and they've got some places 35 million
pounds
coming up just a huge number and i've
got a friend that has the only organic
citrus grove in florida they're
very proud of it they sell it as uncle
max
he was caught in a conundrum and his
news
name are they found glyphosate in orange
juice in florida
which is not surprising at all he tried
to get a
permit to dig an irrigation well and
they would not give him one
they said if you want water for your
trees will give you the waste water from
orlando
and i've got a friend that is an oxford
trained forensic medical pathologist he
did analysis on the water
and it was 24 20 to 40 part per million
glyphosate and it also contained a lot
of pharmaceuticals
and that is why these trees are dying
because roundup works
not like inhibiting the shikomite
pathway but it works by tying up the
minerals needed to
have an immune system and fight off the
root pathogens
so we've got food sources this is what
is allowed by epa
and these levels and standards are not
set
by science they're based on requests by
the herbicide companies
and they go in every so often they raise
them because they want to be
within the standards that are allowed
now
if you have the uh bessie the cow you
can have 400
part per million glyphosate in the hay
that you're eating
number one problem in cattle sometimes
in this country
and in europe germany especially is
botulism
chronic botulism because
uh you kill off the three beneficial
ones which i mentioned earlier
ones that thrive are e coli salmonella
and clostridium
there's effects out there beverage
sources
they tested german beer i think they
were all
contaminated and men had a much higher
glyphosate level
as tested by urine analysis because
germans drink more beer
and my favorite one or steiner wheat is
on there so i don't drink much anymore
at all
so if you're a highbrow californian
might say i don't drink beer i drink
wine
they tested in st louis 14 different
brands some organic wines and
90 of them were contaminated because
usda rules allows organic crops to be
fertilized with
manures from cattle and been fed
gmo brain anyhow
this was a german study they did
basically city dwellers that do not
spray
and it was coming through the food or
the drink
uh fungicides they're used more and more
to fight these diseases
a good friend of mine is a top plant
pathologist with the argentinian usda
and he works with a group called jerkus
was is a japanese usda
and just to prove there were no
fungicide residues in the grain they
finally tested some for the first time
guess what they found
and they've got a real bad sleeping
disease in northern argentina and all of
brazil called
asian rust it's a worst disease plant
disease
people i've ever seen if you see the
plants beginning to turn yellow
there's no way to say them it will die
and we saw it one year wiped about about
million acres of soybeans so it places
the
chinese food supply in jeopardy anyhow
north carolina medical school did a
study
doesn't all show up on this uh slide
but anyhow they the second most common
fungicides used are the strabil urines
they came out of basf as a
stabilized synthetic version of a
strobiliaris
product that prevented other fungi from
utilizing pine cones in the forest as a
food source
but he treated human nerve cells he had
a petri dish
with these fungicides he found severe
neurological damage
to the nerve cells so he's theorizing
that these are tied into
huntington's disease als ms
what have you so they need more studies
yet
lauren pang is the health official
former whole official
on the island of hawaii know him quite
well
in where they've got some severe
problems with pesticide exposure say on
kauai near a town called waimea
the companies have to show a list of
what they were all spraying
and the reason that became a big problem
is there were
times they were spraying uh op
insecticide a neurological
affecting herbicide uh insecticide right
next to the schools
and the winds will change from being 20
miles from the north one minute
five minutes later the 20 minutes from
the south and there were
adults that would have to go to school
take their kids right to the hospital to
have them treated for
an insecticide that companies would not
reveal they had been sprayed
and at night they'd go home and they'd
take their parents to kidney dialysis
because all the dust
that blew into their houses and
they weren't able to get anything done
but what lauren did is when they
say epa test one herbicide they only did
run one task that's all that's required
when you test two products you have to
test product a and product b
and a times b when you've got three you
do a
b c a times b b
times c plus a times c so it was at five
or seven
or if you're exposed to 87 different
things
probably simultaneously that's one times
10 to the 23rd different
cases or combinations you need to test
and they've
only got the money to do five
i mentioned chronic botulism become a
deadly disease
for cattle if you ever hear about 200
cattle all of a sudden being found dead
on a farm
and it's not lightning it's not ufo
damage it's probably chronic botulism
because
what it will do the cattle will get
gaunt
skeletal the mouth will get paralyzed
and they'll just drop over dead in the
stanton because the neurological
toxin will get our botulism toxin gets
so high
now when ladies get a botox injection
that's the same toxin
what the german scientists medical
people have discovered
is most sid's death crib death are due
to exposure to botulism
and a friend of mine was filling in for
don huber when don
was hit in the hospital and he happened
to be out
in maine and was
giving donald's lecture and donna uh
dairy farmer invited him out to come see
his cattle
200 or 150 dairy cows that the farmer is
very proud of
and bill day's farmers that have all
their cow's name that was herds of 20 or
so
and anyhow michael watched them walked
past and
the farmer asked what do you think of my
cattle he said you got a really nice
herd you should be really proud
but you've got three or four that have a
problem
guy asked what do you mean he said i
noticed four are walking
stiffly like their joints are hurting
them and i watched them drink water by
the fountain and they're lapping the
water up instead of drinking it
and he said what might happen you come
in the next two or three days they'll be
dead in the stance
and the farmer asks how do you know this
and mike says well i kind of worked on
that
my previous life which is where that i
talked about that
grinder and and then the
farmer started crying great big 200
pound guy
six foot three and usually farmers don't
start crying like that
mike asked what's the problem he says my
grandson's in the hospital they don't
know what's wrong with them
i mean you're going downhill and mike
says call them up and request a botulism
test right away and they did it was
positive and they saved the kid
anyhow are we seeing it in iowa yeah
major problem in dairy herds california
i've seen it three times in iowa and
it's where they're consuming uh
lights of glyphosate which is screwing
up the the gut
population chronic fatigue
also connected with it
in germany they counter it by taking a
humate product called activa men or
active almond
in this country there are different uh
humate sources
uh one that is commercialized and well
researched is a product called restore
which is developed by a triple
certified medical doctor zach bush it is
sold
in gnc i believe and also walmart for
about 63 dollars
for a bottle that lasts about 96 days
i take it i think everybody should
and i'm working with a another humane
guy out in
idaho and it'll be a powdered pill
rather than a liquid
but what it does it ties up the active
ingredient
in cattle they can also take sauerkraut
juice because sauerkraut
is fermented with the lactobacillus
bacteria
i'm sorry so what does that do exactly
it
uh the lac
if you're trying to get the gut healthy
again the number one thing is to
get rid of the herbicide that diet that
is dirty
and then try to re-establish the gut
population
the number one bacteria beneficial and
being lactobacillus
and solid kraut juice or sauerkraut in
general
contains is fermented using active
bacillus bacteria
that floats into this sauerkraut from
the air
so some
it sold over the counter in germany
a friend of mine that lives along the
mississippi river his level was 13 part
per billion in his urine
and anyhow he is german he went over
there brought the product back it's a
humane pill he made is basically the
shaving
off the top of a coal bed which is made
of old plant parts high in carbon
but you've got a lot of binding sites in
it under a microscope that looks like a
honeycomb
and it ties up the the toxin and then
you crap it out
you said the product was your store
restore it's a liquid product
and uh well researched
by the nih medical community
and if you look up uh do a youtube
either jeffrey smith or dr mercola
interviewing zach bush
zach bush i've got to admit he was on
the patrick
temple's gmo revealed
series and they describe him as probably
the best educated best well-spoken young
physician they've run across and i would
tend to concur
except he gets about three things wrong
but well worth watching
and what he's done uh is he made the
excellent connection between healthy
soil healthy people
uh this was stephanie and anthony's
first talk uh that
when we're in china one of the
presenters was a lady by the name of
rowena or makova
and we had heard about a study where
they fed gm food to
lab animals by the end of the second or
third generation they're all sterile
we heard it was done in russian we
thought well probably done in a bathtub
our old car radiator
well she happens to be head of the
neural uh human behavior
and neural bioscience institute very
good scientist is kind of a good
scientist in russia
and she did not believe the results when
she did it
and usually you don't look at rats and
think those poor little rats
but she didn't believe the results so he
had the study repeated nine times the
results were the same every single time
and i don't know vladimir putin in
person a friend of mine has met with him
several times but
fed said no more gm food in their
country they view
modified food as a germ warfare weapon
as do the chinese wasn't that
study also found that the rats were
growing
but yeah the loss of fecundity was
showing up and repeated nine times and
uh one medical conference i was at was
called the environmental health
medical conference they're having one
in i think scottsdale arizona in april
and anyhow it's the doctors that you go
to when the mayo clinic
says i've got nothing i can do for you i
just go home and prepare to die
and what these doctors do uh every
community i think should have a doctor
trained in this because
without it i'll tell about top 16 out
later
but the learning objective is uh what
they are teaching
people that are just getting introduced
to environmental medicine
if if you have a patient come out do
about a five step
survey
and say
five step survey first of all look and
see what heavy metals they've been
exposed to in
any previous work or hobby
heavy metals what have you number two
look and see what
maybe bacterial fungal mycotoxins they
may have been exposed to number three
look and see what industrial compounds
such as in
paint in wallboard in carpet they've
been exposed to
then look and see what pesticides may be
coming through the food
or the water and then lastly look at
maybe
em emission height levels the electrical
circuitry or gauss's coming from
electronic equipment
a lot of work on cell phones has in
wi-fi has been done
in the netherlands and israel they do
not have been worldwide conferences on
that topic
a friend of mines whose wife was on six
star
sunday morning cbs a few years ago when
they were researching it
caught the start of it before running
out doing some work and i said
that's what bert's wife has and she is a
processing
engineer that taught at a university but
she could no longer tolerate
cell phone power signals and she can't
take the signal from
u.s cellular her sister cannot tolerate
signals from verizon and anyhow they had
her living in a metal travel trailer
inside a machine shed and that still
wasn't enough so she'd get physically
out
they finally sold some ground and they
bought a house in west virginia
where they got a big radio uh telescope
to listen for signals from outer space
and uh that whole valley that people can
have cell phones they can't have wi-fi
and the whole valley which is big in
west virginia is being populated by
people from
around the world that are sensitive to
em signals
uh anyhow the major conference was
chaired by a senator from iowa and joel
lieberman
and they ruled this research is real
people are affected by having health
consequences but
basically major companies utilities and
cell phone companies
were probably at fault partly the
utilities because they take the easy way
to ground their equipment
out now in human medicine it's not
a topic in dairy cattle that are very
sensitive
i've got a couple friends that uh go out
and they diagnose three voltage
and they're very very sometimes are
actually natural because you sit on a
tetronic plate
but they actually clear up the problem
but there is the agenda
there's a list that's kind of what i was
looking for
uh basically look at fam family history
have you a history of disease
why this is important is the number one
detox system in the body
for chemicals and in the plants
herbicides is what's called the p450
cytochrome system
and it allows the body to detox it by
breaking it down
if you've got poor mineralization in
your history
or you've got a lower genetic tolerance
to it
uh you may not be able to detoxify
something
that you're one of your siblings or one
of your cousin can't
that's very important now uh
dow chemical has a dark history and what
it boiled down to
is they were using an organophosphate
insecticide as a termiticide
so people would come and have their
house treated for
termites the vapor would move and if the
kids slept in a downstairs basement
uh the day after it was treated some
of those kids went into a coma that they
were still in 30 years later
and dow was paying for their care and
that was never revealed but a
happy head of a group and the head of
research for that company was
a good was a friend of mine and great
guy to work with and that's why they
moved to using fipronil instead of
the organophosphate much safer and it
lasts longer
so what we talk about what contributes
to total body burden
and basically anytime you're exposed to
something that challenges your
immune function and detox system it's
all cumulative
uh the best uh medical health doctor
in the country that i've run across is
uh
jill carnahan she's an illinois farm gal
and she is a survivor of cancer in
crohn's
and also mold exposure when her boulder
colorado office
was flooded anyhow the way she
related is suppose you've all got your
personal
detox bucket it's a five gallon bucket
and some people's buckets are hinged at
two inches above the ground
others are right at the top and every
time you're exposed to something that
bucket gets filled
forward and fuller when that bucket tips
that's when you get sick so if you can
decontaminate your body or clean out
your liver
the main filtration system in the body
then you're going to stay healthy
and uh you've got different spectrums of
viability
depending on the mineral levels and then
also
your diet and your genetics
the number two system is methylation
there's four of these four minor ones
one major one different symptomology
all the time rashes
sleepiness irritability canker sores
look through there quite a list
i think i only listed half of them here
more red flags allergies
infertility brain fog
the young fellow i've got with me is a
grandson of a good friend of mine that
does a lot of ag writing
very good investigator and anyhow
this kid and his father had severe
problem with brain fog
they started taking the restore which
with the minerals in it
repaired the direct circuitry from the
gut into the brain and brain fog cleared
up within 20 minutes
i started taking one of their products
it was called
h2 and i'm usually usually get six hours
of sleep and i'm wired and going yet at
three
but i was taking that i was going 23
hours a day and i wasn't getting tired
that kind of scared me
because i know you can't do that too
long
but it's an h2 product
so good slide and this i think came from
uh it originally had
sweet crawford in there who was from
dekalb illinois but it said if a woman
is getting out
to get dressed up and go out she's
exposing herself to 187
potential toxins
and this is why i was down in
ecuador working on some rose farms and
long-term potential is to get them
extracting essential oils for the
organic
cosmetic industry in europe
that's where the bumps are anyhow
a lot of things you're probably sitting
there thinking holy crap i use them all
the time
so like running into potential problems
as far as glyphosate exposure anthony
samsel did the study
and the gel caps that most medicines
come in
are made from collagen which comes from
cattle tendons and such they boil them
and they don't give any regards if
there's any glyphosate
eaten by those cattle that is in the gel
caps and also when they make medicines
they use that fermentation
and the media typically will continue
so my wife's name is carol she was
feeling uh
doll and she's she's a live wire she's a
retirement age and she worked 42 years
in a medical lab
and anyhow rachel
did a over the phone exposure because
that's richard's gift
go listen to him and he listened and she
was full of fluoride
4x normal levels with the hair analysis
showed where did she get it from
at the time we thought it was from
bottled water and from
taking cholesterol drugs statins
because they're fluoride based anyhow uh
she went to arden anderson who's a
head's our think tank group and he's a
md ph.d masters in public health
agronomist air force flight surgeon so
he's pretty good
and went to his uh got an adt a
chelation
from him in his office west of kansas
city
and it came back and her body ate high
cholesterol and also stopped like on
fire
so they did the et chelation 24-hour
urine catch they sent it to the lab
came back and she was full of lead
gallatin galidenium thorium
caesium and they said where
might these have come from what was your
job well
iowa state university in the doe lab is
their
center for rare earth research and
they're refining them
in the floor right above her my first
question
is did they have a separate ventilation
system the answer was no
so she was full of these and why she had
the high level of cholesterol
is if this was causing inflammation and
the
body knows that it's the liver to go
into high gear
reduce as much as you can to protect the
brain
so she went down had a full body
chelation by the top
doctor in the country who's also in the
think tank down in beaumont
down in kirbyville texas and after nine
sessions they dropped her
cholesterol level by over 100 points got
rid of the ache
and the pains and she's ready to go for
another 20 years
so anyhow most people don't know about
that they sit there
she went to the doctor and the doctor
said she couldn't sleep either
and her solution all the problem is take
a sleeping pill
so that's why i think more people need
to be aware of this and be aware that
turn of the century most hospitals had a
chelation office
but what they do this guy besides being
a medical doctor
it was a physicist he built his own
equipment
but they take the blood out they run it
through a uv
light they subject it to ozone to get
more oxygen in there
and they inject the edt8 which is a
universal solvent
but she got rid of the plaque of her
blood vessels
83 year old friend of mine he gets a
chelation
about twice a year he's got zero plaque
in his blood vessels
the only thing he's got wrong with his
health he's got angina because he
put his cell phone in his shirt pocket
for too many years
so i'm going down there i
great health but i know i like steak i
like
french fries sometimes i fry hash browns
i'm going down there just because i know
the years i've got some plaque probably
so it's there as far as mold what do we
do
we're down in ecuador and along the
coast everyone's got
mold problems if you're in hawaii major
problem
even in fancy houses they pulled the
they didn't know where the mold was they
took the wallpaper down guess where it
was
it was growing on the glue which is
scottish based
in the house in a nice house you think
there's no mold
except and that one place is on the sofa
cushions so uh continuous problem
serious problem again symptoms
associated with it
many there's 14 different ones i think
there's two pages
28 major mycotoxins ingrained
the thing is if they're coming at you
you don't know they're there
because they're tough to detect and also
say one major one
of the t2 toxins there's 400 of them
only one has been researched the other
399 have been researched but the
data is still classified top secret by
the us military
and what we're seeing now with more root
rots
because glyphosate kills off the
beneficial bacteria in the soil
the fusarium and aspergillus
molds are increasing and showing up in
the diet
this oxford trained medical pathologist
went into a local grocery store and he's
got the old rebel type but he
went and grabbed samples from 20 boxes
of kids cereal
none of them tested under the allowable
level for mycotoxins
again health effects of fungi breathe in
there
numerous common symptoms
ones that most people have at some time
maybe all the times
again symptoms metallic taste
quite common sometimes uh
supposed not supposed to reveal this yet
but uh
will anyhow we had the bird flu come
through iowa
supposedly a viral disease things were
extremely fishy with it
different producers were told anybody in
my group
do not allow feed samples to be taken
anyhow it ended up in 46 million
chickens and turkeys ended up being
destroyed
sometimes multi-million dollar losses
and then a major problem with disposing
of the carcasses
anyway i was sitting there mentioning to
a water research friend of mine
i made the comment wouldn't it be nice
if someone had a machine you could sit
down
and using either electronic waves or
some sort of smell wipe out all the
bacteria and fungi that are causing the
problem
well one of these has been developed it
was tested by the world health
organization
and he was called to testify in front of
the whole over in italy
three weeks ago and this device we hope
to get on the market
looks good
we've got a health and wellness page we
uh put a website together with the help
of the guy that did the website for
steppenwolf
and a grateful dead and we put a lot of
our own content in there
and we have a health solution store up
there for people trying to get the
information
and uh a good example if you're a
teacher or have kids
there was a school in wisconsin up at
appleton
and it was a school for behavior or
disordered kids and uh
delinquents kids that didn't go to
school getting bad grades didn't want to
study
true what have you and an outside
consultant came in that had a good idea
on diet and he looked at the doctor he
said everything junk
let's get rid of the pop let's get rid
of the high fructose corn syrup
let's uh put better food in there which
ended up being cheaper
and after three months
all the kids were perfect no behavior
problems that was
one of the better performing high
schools in the state of wisconsin
and nationally and anyhow the officials
were told whatever you do don't
tell anyone else about this thing
but a daughter a friend of ours happen
to know about this
but it's called you can google it
miracle in wisconsin
some neat stories but it was proof that
all these toxins that are in the grain
mycotoxins poor diet
does have consequences shows up in the
kids because they're younger they don't
have the big
fully functioning immune system so
recommendations then for all these
problems we tell people clean up the
food supply
use restore or this hopefully to get on
the market
called the molecule to repair the gut
tract tissue and then to get rid of any
prions which were not in the food supply
and maybe are linked to alzheimer's
because it's a plaque disease
uh anthony samsel has done a lot of work
on it he concurs with that
but there is clean optilite available i
get mine from a micro minerals company
out of
the netherlands i have don bring it back
when he comes to europe
nine grams per day there is a small
religious community in illinois and
one of the leaders of the church was in
our group and owns a seed company
and we're down there putting on a
meeting and all of a sudden being as an
elder in the church
he got word that this lady in his
community had miscarried for the third
or fourth time in a row
and they had not had a live birth in
their community for a year
and we sent
some placental tissue down to the vet
pathologist that had done the work on
the
large animals and the placental tissue
was full of these crystals
and the next question is what do we do
about it and some amish guy came up with
a solution before we could figure it out
but
they started taking the clinton out till
the light and within nine months they're
going to have a light burst in the
community again
we've seen the same thing in animals
point nine grams per day
in with the juice the same thing if
you're
tr ha if somebody your family is being
treated for
a cancerous tumor the best way to shrink
the size of the tube and maybe make it
disappear
is take this because it chelates out the
iron
and energy is delivered to the tumor by
a charged iron
so if you take it they say take mineral
supplements at the same time
so where is this available in the u.s
different health food stores sell it
they jack the price up quite a bit
i get mine for maybe 10 a pound
out of micro minerals in the netherlands
if you anyone in your family has
aquariums
and you can go to the aquarium store and
get a filter that pulls the ammonia out
of the water
that's called zeolite it's volcanic
mineral when they grind it
smaller then it comes to an optilite
i'll last the fertility organic growers
will use a product called
azolite hazelnite is also
zeolite uh we work with a couple
uh our medical doctors environmental
health medical people
taught one's from illinois there's a
real good one from out in
mount shasta california they work with
us
as far as the effect of all of these
exposures we don't quite know
michael k skinner was a good
researcher at washington state
university and in his
uh multi-year study he exposed lab
animals to
[Music]
five different toxins at levels one one
hundredth of what was considered harmful
and the genetic damage was done and the
damage did not show up until the third
generation
later again they censored him on that
i showed the restored product very
usable
my friend that developed the other
machine has his phd in biophysics from
oxford and tokyo he developed an under
the counterfeit system for about 1500
that will pull the roundup out of
drinking water
so if you've got a water supply that is
coming stream fed
you always want to look upstream and ask
what crops are being grown
and what pesticides are they're using if
it's a pesticide with a
long residual life then you should have
your urine tested
which can be done by john fagan at his
lab in fairfield iowa it's called
research health lab
and he's got the equipment to test for
glyphosate and its primary metabolite
which is called
ampa amino methylphosphonic acid
but you should have that done i've had
it done but that was when they're using
immunoassay which was not
as accurate as what the germans could do
so i need to get that done i've got a
kit paid for just haven't done it
there's the under the counter
works very well does he talk to don
huber he found out the
chelation quotient
you